the Indians manager Terry Francona
joining us on the program Terry how are
you this morning
hello Dan how are you I'm doing great
but I'm worried about you you know your
teeth the cap falls out you got to go to
the doctor where are you right now I'm
actually standing at the Cleveland
Clinic in the lobby I just dropped off
an exam and I'm going for a doctor
appointment just to uh you know at the
end of the year they always do the
annual check the body parts see which
ones have broken down a little bit too
much so today's my last appointment
the years not over couldn't you have
waited two weeks well I think that I get
I'll tell you what they take such good
care of me here and we've had some you
know when you have when you have a night
workout might as well come this morning
and get some of this stuff out of the
way so when the season is over then they
can figure out which body parts to fix
ER to get rid of or whatever replace did
you lose a tooth or a cap oh no I lost
like a veneer yes if you've had those
you know when it comes off is all this
left is like a stub so one it wasn't
real real good-looking and two you know
when you have tobacco like rubbing on it
for nine innings didn't feel that great
and it happened between the anthem and
the game so it was literally five
minutes before the game do you have a
dentist on call no no but they it's
funny because you know I took my
l'avenir to our trainer and I was you
know I thought I said hey tell the
dentist back in Cleveland I'm gonna
punch him in the face and I said can you
find me a dentist tomorrow and about
four innings later he came running out
of the dugout I said what'd you find
he said well I wanted to tell you about
Trevor and I said I don't care right now
about Trevor I said why don't forget my
tooth thank you and that night about one
o'clock in the morning a tennis to
Toronto met me and fixed my tooth I was
beyond appreciative and I couldn't
believe he did it was one of the nicest
things anybody's ever done now he was
gonna update you on Trevor Bauer but yet
Trevor came out of that game with the
bloody fingers
yeah and I was like hey man I thought
you're coming to tell me about my later
did he hide his finger from you before
he went to the mound wait did he what
did he hide his finger the fact that he
was
I mean how bad it was were you aware
that it was just one stitch away from
you know gushing all over the mound well
yeah yeah but that's not really exactly
the case um none of the stitches gave
way it was actually the medical people
the doctors are trash did a really good
job I mean it looked ugly cuz my
goodness he cut the heck out of it but
what happened was there was a piece of
skin down towards the end and it was
kind of dead and that was the issue it's
almost like a flap and that slap gave
way the stitches held so out of a little
area he bled like crazy I mean you could
imagine now you're throwing and you know
you're pumping the blood and you know
his fingers you know then he stands
there and it's that kind of dangling so
it started to bleed you know pretty
aggressively
um I don't think he hid anything from us
we you know Mickey was down in the
bullpen watched him warm up I mean it
didn't start bleeding until it's kind of
started coming out so hopefully with
some more time you know a little bit
more work done on that he'll be able to
keep it together this time did you think
you had another curt schilling moment
here no no I really didn't I mean that
that's I didn't think about to be honest
with you but I mean you know it's pretty
it's pretty different I mean what she'll
did one two labels were out there yeah
which is a big difference but what
she'll did show at no business bitching
I mean I I kind of get irritated when
people talk about that maybe they poopoo
it because I got to see it firsthand he
had no business bitching and not only
did he pitch but he won and I guess that
shows the amount of confidence I had him
is that I never doubted that he would
figure something out I didn't know that
they would go to those kind of lengths
but that's just how much how much
conviction I had a shill he's Terry
Francona the Indians manager Game one of
the World Series coming up tomorrow
night
how many phone calls do you get for
tickets uh you know what I actually
started to count because I got a little
bit frustrated I have
over 200 requests for tickets which is
disappointing because you know the last
thing you ever want to do is let
somebody down but at some point it gets
to be a little ridiculous and you know
like we talked to the team about you
know take care of all the detail stuff
so the game does makeup on you and then
I was kind of laughing with them the
other day I said you're anything like me
you're getting new friends by the minute
and everybody thinks they're the only
person asking you for ticket I I know
and you know what like I said you don't
want to let people down but but my
goodness it gets hard
I mean Wrigley Field is it doesn't
exactly seat a hundred thousand people
and they haven't been there in what 71
years so that's a tough ticket and it's
getting tougher and you certainly want
your family or your kids or whoever to
be able to go so it's and I don't think
people realize you have to buy these
tickets like two weeks before the
playoffs start and then whatever you
bought you have and then it's hard
getting more you know I can't help but
you know look back and I saw some great
compliments from your current players
about your laid-back clubhouse demeanor
but then that was supposed to be part of
the reason why you got fired in Boston
did you think about altering your
personality at all after what happened
in Boston is that even possible what day
and that's actually a really good point
you know I guess the conclusion I came
to was you know in in Boston the last
year I mean that last month was tough I
mean we were what seven and twenty three
and I really thought as a manager the
biggest thing you can do is be
consistent you know if I started going
off on people and you know for this and
that I mean they're they're gonna you
know they view that as panic so you kind
of have your personality and and you
know you try to have it through good and
through bad and then sometimes when it
doesn't work you know like it's time to
move on which I which I understand but
you also try to learn as you go I think
you know if you don't know you're
missing the boat but I'm pretty
fortunate here I think you know the
players obviously do a great job
it allows me to maybe show my
personality a little bit more because
they handle what they're supposed to and
I don't have to get after them very
often and then my boss is here I think
bring out maybe a better person in me
which is important because in this game
man you can get frustrated you can get
stubborn all those things good things to
have and they just they take care of me
so well and I think they've got a better
person if you can give us a little
insight into the scouting report of what
concerns you more if you had to pick the
pitching staff or the hitting of the
Cubs well because we went over the
hitters yesterday I would say the
hitters but we're gonna go over the
pitchers today and in a good Channel
oh yeah oh you will change because when
you look at Lester Arrieta Hendricks I
mean they've they've all given up I
think 4050 less hits then innings which
is incredible and then he got Lackey
following them there they're starting
pitching is phenomenal and you know
they're I think it goes unnoticed how
good how well they play defensively you
know they've signed some really key guys
you know like well they signed Ben
Zobrist I don't know how much publicity
it got or not but it's a guy that can
move anywhere and he's so reliable
wherever you put them so you know you
added a switch hitting middle of the
order bad but also gotta catch the ball
everywhere that kind of moved
complements everybody else you get
pregame speeches no no I've never do
this no no it's not football I mean if
they're not ready to go by and the game
starts or trouble in baseball you can't
do that you know we play every day those
guys will go deaf on you I mean I've
probably met with this team more this
year than I ever have just because some
of the guys asked me to do that last
year
and so I tried to pay attention to a
little bit more this year and we've met
before every series just to spend five
minutes on hey here's what's ahead of us
and here's how we're going to do it and
they've been terrific about it you talk
to Theo Epstein at all while texted with
him a bunch I mean I saw him in spring
training he actually came down during a
game and we kind of talked during
but I texted with him a lot during the
year something funny comes up or
something that you know I thought he'd
get a kick out of or he does the same
with me um you know we there's usually a
funny text waiting so but and you know I
got a congratulations from him the other
night and I sent him one the other day
and I'm sure I'll see him today I know
they got in last night and they're
practicing before us today so I'll see
him today
have you played this series out in your
mind never can it as I think last series
shows I mean you try to be prepared for
everything because you know you don't
know what's going to happen but I think
you also are trying to be prepared for
things that can go wrong and then not
let that derail the series you know you
might lose a game but you don't want it
to affect the next game and certainly
you know our our formula is pretty
simple you want to get a lead and turn
it over to the bullpen it doesn't it
doesn't and you know guarantee a win but
that's the way we need to win before I
let you go is there a time when you
would not bring in Andrew Miller like as
far as the inning that you brought him
in in the fifth inning before so would
you bring him in in the third or fourth
I don't know I mean I guess I just you
know I try to use common sense with with
him and having common sense in the
middle of a game is hard because I mean
I'm serious you got emotions and you
know I mean I've talked to our bullpen
guys and they know how I feel about it
you know I don't want us to lose a game
sitting with Andrew Miller out of the
bullpen not pitching and the same with
Cody Allen and and again to an extent
Brian Shaw I mean they all complement
each other and it doesn't work with
Andrew if Cody and Jacques can't do
their jobs so we've been pretty
fortunate in that since Andrews been
here I mean those those other guys were
mainstays here but they've actually been
better since Andrews been here yeah we
called him the mild thing when Andrew
was with us last week he's not the wild
thing he's the mild thing there's no
bulletin board material there with that
good these he understands that he's a
great kid and you know there's a reason
we you up for good players form I mean
is kind of how we envisioned it it
doesn't always work that way but it
certainly has for us this year have fun
at the game not at the doctor's office
and thanks for joining us Terry
I will then thanks so much take care all
right Terry Francona his friends call
him Tito Continental Tire coaches or
managers corner for any surface every
season there's Continental Tire that
delivers superior performance and
unparalleled safety give your vehicle an
upgrade with Continentals maximum
performance tires for more info on the
tire that's right for you check out
Continental Tire calm from speedway to
the driveway Continental put you in the
driver's seat always fun to talk to him
he is one of 15 managers in baseball
history to take two different teams to
the World Series if the Indians would
happen to win he'd be just the fifth
manager to win World Series titles with
two teams stat of a day sad is a day
that passed out of the day stat of the
day here comes that what stat of the day
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience